the nightmare that shocked a nation
where many had suffocated in a
bottleneck a wall of remembrance now
stands I still don't understand how
something like this could happen to us a
year flew by I can't imagine how it's
been for the families a year ago the
first Halloween weekend after pandemic
restrictions were lifted this nightlife
Hotpot of e Taiwan Drew an influx of
people with little crowd control and
help was slow to arrive now this is the
narrow Alleyway where 158 people were
fatally crushed that night now to
prevent a reoccurrence soul City says it
will install more security cameras
optimized with AI video analysis that
will enable it to more quickly find
dangerous spots in addition to
monitoring crowds police and
firefighters will be required to respond
if three emergency calls are made within
50 meters of each other but grieving
families say they're still seeking
answers to basic questions from that
night why a victims declare time of
death doesn't match the official
timeline of events why fire Crews were
kept from immediately taking the wounded
to hospitals and why they've yet to
receive an apology in person for the
botched
response the government including the
president and the safety Minister
apologized many times in front of
but if we the breathed families try to
meet them they just ignore us for us the
itan disaster is
ongoing will there ever be some type of
closure for us we need closure we need
an exclanation to be able to properly
grief so far no high level government
official has been dismissed for the
man-made disaster families say they will
keep fighting for an independent inquiry
to seek accountability and
closure Unis Kim aljazera
Soul make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer